[Música]
bienvenidos a un nuevo capítulo de
áfrica siete días aquí en france 24 este
es un magazine informativo 100% dedicado
al continente africano
yo soy liliana valencia aquí llevamos
una mirada en profundidad los hechos de
actualidad de la semana en la cuna de la
humanidad
entre los meses de octubre y diciembre
de 2020 se vive un intenso calendario
electoral en el continente africano 7
naciones la mayoría de ellas en áfrica
occidental eligen presidentes en medio
del temor a que se desaten hechos de
violencia después de los comicios
en la república de guinea los ciudadanos
están convocados a las urnas para elegir
entre un posible nuevo mandato del
presidente alpha condé que aspira la
reelección o un sucesor de este
mandatario la ciudadanía pide mejoras en
temas de salud trabajo y también en
educación
entre tanto costa de márfil se alista
para votar el próximo 31 de octubre en
medio de tensiones entre los candidatos
dos de ellos pidieron el boicot de los
comicios mientras el presidente alassane
ouattara intenta mantenerse al mando del
país tenemos el reporte desde abiyán
iniciamos entonces con la información
aquí en áfrica 710 en esta emisión
hablamos de política porque siete países
del continente están convocando
elecciones presidenciales para el último
trimestre de este año
demos un repaso a las fechas del
calendario electoral para el continente
entre octubre y diciembre el primero es
república de guinea o guinea conakry el
18 de octubre donde el presidente alpha
condé busca la reelección también
tenemos a tanzania que vota el próximo
28 de octubre donde también el
presidente john mcfall y busca un
segundo mandato más adelante esta costa
de márfil el 31 de octubre con la
candidatura del presidente alassane
ouattara y la ausencia de loren 'bad
boy' y guillaume soro
después burkina faso el 22 de noviembre
también tiene al presidente de rock mar
cristian kaboré aspirando a la
reelección el 7 de diciembre del turno
de ghana donde el mandatario nana
akufo-addo busca también la reelección
frente al ex presidente
mahatma después viene en níger el 27 de
diciembre que espera lograr su primera
transición pacífica de poder que la
misma fecha la república centroafricana
donde el ex presidente françois bozizé
regresar al poder
pues justamente la república de guinea
también conocida como guinea conakry la
pandemia de ccoo y 19 agudizado la
crisis económica y la mayoría de los
trabajadores están en la informalidad
educación salud y empleo juvenil son
algunas de las prioridades de los
ciudadanos en estas elecciones
presidenciales
madina desde el centro comercial más
grande de conakry miles de guineanos se
reúnen aquí todos los días para realizar
diversas actividades comerciales a
medida que se esperan las elecciones
presidenciales las expectativas de los
votantes son varias
boubacar es un vendedor de teléfonos
inteligentes espera que el empleo
juvenil sea la prioridad para el futuro
ganador de la contienda la marina y si
me abocó leyendo aquí en marina muchos
jóvenes que se están graduando de la
universidad graduados sin logros vienen
a madina para salir adelante no hay
trabajo quisiera que el nuevo presidente
revise el trabajo de los jóvenes a
través de sesiones loser según el banco
mundial el 55% de la población guineana
vive por debajo del umbral de pobreza
una situación agravada aún más por la
crisis sanitaria consecuencia del
coronavirus que provocó la subida de los
precios de los alimentos
esta familia de los suburbios de conakry
desea poder aumentar su poder
adquisitivo tranquilo y luciano las
enanismo cuando pagas 50.000 francos
guineano por un kilo de carne y luego
cuando quieras hacer una salsa gasta 100
mil guineas
en francia no es nada fácil para
nosotros doble y el pescado todo es caro
me gustaría que el nuevo presidente haga
algo para mejorar esto usarlo
a pesar de sus muchas potencialidades
especialmente en el sector minero guinea
está luchando por levantarse 62 años
después de su independencia para este
comerciante que se ha embarcado en el
sector de la salud la prioridad
fortalecer el estado de derecho
para mí ante todo está el respeto a las
leyes a la justicia social para todos la
educación y la salud
después de guinea ocupa el puesto 175 de
189 países según el índice de desarrollo
humano del programa de las naciones
unidas razón por la cual los retos del
presidente siguen siendo descomunales
pero además uno de los mayores desafíos
de las elecciones en la república de
guinea es que los comicios y los días
posteriores transcurran en paz la
oposición ha contado más de 100 muertos
durante manifestaciones en contra del
presidente alpha condé desde su llegada
al poder hace 10 años por eso ahora
grupos de jóvenes desarrollan diversas
iniciativas ciudadanas para promover la
paz en el contexto electoral que se vive
en el país
[Música]
unos días antes de las elecciones
presidenciales aumentan los llamados a
la calma y los grandes de la música
guineana están a la vanguardia
[Música]
reunidos en el colectivo llamado guinea
al stars invitan a sus compatriotas a
escuchar un nuevo hit nuestra línea
sean vistas juppé es un mensaje de paz
pero al mismo tiempo hay un mensaje de
justicia ya que sin justicia no hay paz
que de sampson justicia padre pepe guti
vale parlophone nuestros aficionados nos
escuchan también transmitirán el mensaje
que estamos transmitiendo creo que
tendrá un impacto y supones que estaba
salvado formando ni en empacho las
acciones para prevenir la violencia
también son visibles en la web a blog y
la asociación de blogueros de guinea
lucha contra la difusión de discursos de
odio en las redes sociales y cuenta con
la cooperación de los guineanos
les pedimos que no envíen estos
comentarios negativos para que los
enumeremos y podamos tomar las mejores
acciones para limitarlos y por lo tanto
limitar su impacto de laurent para los
religiosos no se quedan atrás en ese
impulso para unir aún más a los
guineanos el hardware iba diaby creó una
fundación voluntaria que trabaja por la
fase electoral a medida que se acercan
las elecciones realizan recorridos de
sensibilización en los suburbios de
conakry donde los jóvenes se enfrentan
regularmente a la policía durante las
manifestaciones
y también en costa de márfil colectivos
de periodistas y activistas trabajan
para que las nuevas generaciones
entiendan el valor de la democracia por
medio de dibujo les enseñan la
importancia a mantener la paz durante
los procesos electorales
todos estos jóvenes de esta sala
recuerdan la violencia de 2010 aquí
estamos sin como la ciudad más grande
del norte de costa de marfil también
está aquí donde los periodistas del
colectivo tanto decidieron instalarse y
partimos de la observación de que cada
vez que las elecciones llevaron a la
violencia y la mayoría de las veces son
los jóvenes en los que son manipulados
para llegar a este tipo de deriva
pensamos que como a los jóvenes les
gusta el dibujo teníamos que ir a ellos
y hacerles conscientes de la importancia
de las elecciones facilidad a través del
dibujo
apc
el dibujo también es una manera de
reducir la desigualdad frente a la
información en el país en el que más de
la mitad de la población es analfabeta
acompañando al caricaturista de prensa y
un experto en democracia los jóvenes
analizan dibujos con mensajes fuertes
me doy cuenta de que es un niño que está
siendo invadido por la violencia en su
cabeza a este niño está mal informado
tiene pensamientos negativos está armado
mentalmente
el objetivo es ayudarles a debatir con
cortar sus ideas y sobre todo entender
que no todos tienen la misma opinión la
mañana no creo que no irá bien porque
guillaume soro dijo que no habrá
elecciones sin él pues creo que irá bien
porque hay mucha gente luchando para que
estas elecciones vayan bien yo también
estoy con ellos
el 31 de octubre será una oportunidad
para ver si el trabajo de
sensibilización de los jóvenes han dado
sus frutos y si se puede evitar las
violencias que sacudió el país durante
las elecciones de 2010
pues justamente hay expectativa en costa
de marfil ante las elecciones del
próximo 31 de octubre en las cuales el
presidente alassane ouattara buscará la
reelección a parte del actual mandatario
el candidato más opcionado es el ex
presidente henri konan bédié quien
cuenta con el apoyo de los dos grandes
ausentes loren 'bad boy' y homs oro él
junto al también candidato opositor
pascal affi instaron a sus seguidores a
boicotear activamente el proceso
electoral desde abiyán os informó
previamente nuestra corresponsal maría
con él
de los cuatros candidatos sólo dos alas
and run anotaba y cuatro con alberto han
presentado sus programas para las
elecciones presidenciales en la ciudad
de abiyán hay docenas panelas
publicitarias del actual presidente
alassane ouattara prometiendo a los
marfileños la construcción de una costa
de marfil fuerte en cuanto a los
candidatos con nombres de pascal affi
ingresó el líder de la oposición ellos
anuncian que no se ven afectados por el
proceso electoral y piden a los
marfileños que bloquean el proceso
electoral y que no recuperan su tarjeta
de votante básicamente ellos piden el
boicot de las elecciones presidenciales
los dos candidatos que habían llamado a
la población a la desobediencia civil a
principios de octubre critican el actual
presidente al asad la mano atada por
querer hacer un tercer mandato cuando la
constitución del país permite solamente
dos según ellos es imposible realizar
elecciones presidenciales trans
barrantes con la costa de la comisión
electoral del país que ellos consideran
al servicio del acto el gobierno todas
estas naciones políticas hacen temer una
violencia crisis post-electoral en el
país como la de 2010
y cambiamos de información porque del 12
al 31 de octubre se realiza en colombia
la decimotercera versión del encuentro
de etnoeducadores áfrica en la escuela
un evento creado para promover la
enseñanza de la historia africana en los
colegios y universidades del país este
año el evento se realiza de manera
virtual debido a la pandemia de cubi 19
sobre la iniciativa hablamos con su
directora maría isabel mena desde
colombia
en conjunto con líderes y lideresas
maestros maestras activistas nos hemos
encargado de generar la idea
que los niños los estudiantes en el
sistema educativo tienen que conocer la
historia de áfrica así como conocer la
historia de otros continentes no nos
podemos perder esta información porque
es la historia de la humanidad entendida
como la historia de todos los seres
humanos que se unan en el continente
africano hoy debemos decir que áfrica en
la escuela es un movimiento pedagógico
inspirado en esta necesidad de que los
estudiantes toquen el mapa de áfrica
entiendan las culturas africanas voy a
situar el relieve africano entre otras
manifestaciones específicas de ese
continente les invitamos a seguir esta
iniciativa que es la que puede
transformar el sistema educativo en un
sistema más multicultural más polifónico
más lleno de unas ideas concretas y
completas sobre quiénes son los dueños
de la epopeya humana los aplicaron y sus
descendientes
y finalizamos con música que nos llega
desde etiopía el único país de áfrica
que nunca fue colonizado esta canción se
llama gonder y es el más reciente
lanzamiento de casa un detalle en ella
junto a otros artistas de las nuevas
generaciones están retomando los ritmos
tradicionales de este país así
finalizamos en aplica 7 días ustedes
continúen con más en nuestra página web
france24 puntocom nos vemos más adelante
con más información
mi nombre
m
[Música]
d
y muchas ganas
muy bien lo mismo